let's say that we have three vectors
vectors a B and C and we know that
vector A plus vector B plus vector B is
equal to is equal to vector C now given
this I have some interesting questions
can you construct a scenario where the
magnitude the magnitude of vector C is
equal to the magnitude the magnitude of
vector A plus the magnitude of vector B
plus the magnitude of vector B and can
you also using potentially different
vectors a and B construct a scenario
where the magnitude of vector C is
greater than the magnitude the magnitude
of vector A plus the magnitude the
magnitude of vector B so I encourage you
to pause this video right now and try to
do that try to come up with some vectors
a and B so that when you take their sum
that the magnitude of the sum is equal
to the sum of the magnitudes and also
see if you could come up with some
vectors a and B so that if you take if
you take the sum of the vectors that the
magnitude of the sum is actually greater
than the sum of the magnitudes so see if
you can come up with that
well let's I'm assuming you've given a
go at it and potentially you've gotten a
little bit frustrated especially with
the second one so the only way let's
let's actually just draw some vectors so
if you have vector a like this and let's
say vector B vector B looks something
like that then a plus B let's see we can
just shift this over copy and paste a
plus B is going to look a plus B is
going to look like this a plus B or
vector C I guess we could say is going
to look is going to look like that and
notice these three vectors always form a
triangle and if you have a triangle one
side cannot be longer than the other
- then the sum of the other two sides
think about it if you wanted it if you
wanted this to be if you wanted this to
be longer what you could try to do what
you could try to do is maybe change
vector B in a way so you're pushing it
further and further out so you could
maybe you could if you changed your
vector B a little bit you can get this
vector C to be longer and longer so
maybe if you made your vector B like
this maybe your vector B you would look
something like this now your vector C is
getting pretty long but it's still
shorter than then the sum of these two
sides and to make it equal to the sum of
these two sides you essentially have to
make these two vectors go in the exact
same direction so to make it equal you
have to have vector a looking like this
and you have to change the direction of
vector B or essentially construct a
vector B that's going in the exact same
direction so it's going in the exact
same direction only in this circumstance
will you get will you get this scenario
where vector the magnitude of vector C
is equal to so really the the largest
the largest of the magnitude of the sum
can be is the sum of the magnitudes and
that only happens when these two are
going in the same direction so these are
going in the same in the exact same
direction this right over here is
impossible you can never get one side of
a triangle being longer than the sum of
the other two sides based on what we
just saw now you probably say well what
about the circumstance where the
magnitude of our sum where the magnitude
of our sum is less than is less than the
magnitude of then the sum of the
magnitudes I guess I could say and this
is fairly difficult this is pretty much
always the scenario this is what's going
to always be the case when the vectors
are not going to be in when the vectors
are not in the same direction so if
someone is someone drew a vector like
this it can be drawn a little bit
straighter if someone drew a vector like
this and a vector like this
these clearly are not going in the same
direction so the sum of these two
vectors the magnitude of that is going
to be less than the sum of these two
magnitudes so for example if the
magnitude here is 5 and the magnitude
here is 3 then we know that if we were
to add these two things let me let me
just show you so copy and paste so if we
were to actually let me just cut and
paste so that we can clean things up a
little bit so cut and paste so let's add
these two vectors so we know we know
that the sum of these two which is going
to be this vector right over here its
magnitude its magnitude is going to be
less than it's going to be less than 5
plus 3 is going to be less than 8 the
only way that this magnitude could even
get to 8 is if these two vectors went in
the exact same went in the exact same
direction